they're packing up for their regular
worker feeding the hungry and homers but
in recent weeks the pressure on Red
Cross workers in Brussels has
intensified not only are they struggling
to plug gaps in basic social care in the
city but they're paramedics have been
deployed to help in the frontline battle
against coronavirus Luke Pullman works
on one of the coded only ambulances in
Belgium's capital and says the work is
relentless Venkat resolvent cat
mister my pleasure more a shock fan
mission over mission we preview the
leaders in situation on the gear
I only say the fair maximum see the
sooner she no hostile her maximum the
victim she's worn a lupito as the team
head out for their night's work helping
the estimated 2,500 homeless people in
the city they know many will be more
desperate than usual the lockdown has
kept most residents off the streets and
passing donations have dried up as
people emerge from subways and
underpasses they're asked if they have
any symptoms of the virus along with
food they're offered toiletries and told
about the importance of washing their
hands and keeping their distance from
people by giving everybody soap
Tuesday's shaving kits and to today to
make them aware about some symptoms they
can remark if there are if there are
running nose
curves throughout the night people come
to the stands around the city for help
some tell us they've been fined by the
police for being out on the street
simply sitting on a bench but when
you're homeless where do you go during a
lockdown most wonder how they're going
to survive the coming weeks it's very
difficult because this is no no
no no pupil and this empty city like I
said it is unbelievable is collapse it's
more difficult than it's done every day
is because know there is no money people
in the streets who can give you
something to eat or something or money
or anything else they know a sandwich
and a hot drink thanks to the Red Cross
may be their only daily meal for a long
time to come and the Red Cross staff
know the demands or nemr
only set to increase Michelle Clifford
Sky News Brussels